[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور لمخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين في مدينه صيدا جنوب
لبنان واخبار عن التوتر واشتباك مستمر
هناك
وفي مواضيع الحسد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
تحركات اقليميه ودوليه لحمل قاده الانقلاب
على اعاده السلطه والافراج عن رئيس النيجر
مجموعه تفرض عقوبات وتمهل الانقلابيين
اسبوعا واحدا وتلوح باستخدام القوه رئيس
تشاد في نيامي موفدا عن الاكواس للتوصل
الى التسويه
وفرنسا تهدد برد فوري على اي استهداف
لمصالحها او قواتها بعد مهاجمه المتظاهرين
لسفارتها في النيجر
مخيم عين الحلوه في لبنان محور توتر من
جديد
اشتباكات تسفر عن مقتل سته اشخاص بينهم
قائد الامن الوطني الفلسطيني في صيدا
واصابه عشره
الجيش اللبناني يقول ان عددا من جنوده
اصيبوا في اطلاق نار من داخل المخيم ورئيس
الوزراء اللبناني يصف توقيت الاشتباكات
بالمشبوح في ظل الظرف الاقليمي والدولي
ويدعوا لضبط الوضع في المخيم واحترام
سياده لبنان
بعد يوم على استهداف روستوس وسماره في
الداخل الروسي موسكو تتعرض لهجوم
اوكرانيين بالمسيرات يتسبب في اغلاق مؤقت
لاحد مطاراتها الدوريه السلطات الروسيه
تؤكد اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات في العاصمه
واحباطه هجوم مماثل في القرن وزيلسكي يقول
ان ارتداد الحرب الى الداخل الروسي امر
حتمي
وفي لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم التطورات في مخيم عين
الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين في لبنان
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما اسباب عوده
التوتر الى مخيم عين الحلوه الاجابه جاءت
على الشكل التالي
37% قالوا ان السبب هو خلافات داخل المخيم
بينما ارجع نحو 17% الامر الى مسائل امنيه
عالقه اخيرا اعتقد نحو سته واربعين في
المئه انا السبب يتعلق بسياق من خارج
المخيم
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصوير عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
اللقاء على منصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
الكوبالت استثمار الصين في الكونغو ومحور
سجال مع سلطاتها
[موسيقى]
اقرت قمه المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا الاكواس اجراءات عقابيه على
السلطه الانقلابيين في النيجر تتضمن
عقوبات ماليه
وتقييد سفرهم كما لوحت بتدخل عسكري في حال
عدم اعاده الرئيس محمد بزوم الى السلطه في
غضون اسبوع واحد وفي رد فعل على التظاهرات
امام سفاره الفرنسيه في النيام حذر من
التعرض لقواته او بعثاته الدبلوماسيه
تفاصيل قمه اكوس والمشهد الميداني في
النيجر نتابعها معا في هذا التقرير
عقوبات على النيجر هذا ما انتهت اليه قمه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
ايكووس التي اجتمعت بشكل طارئ بعد ايام
على الانقلاب في نيامي الاجراءات العقابيه
تضمنت عقوبات ماليه واخرى تتعلق بتقييد
السفر ومنطقه حظر طيران ولعل اخطر ما خلصت
اليه القمه التلويح بتدخل عسكري لكن
اللافته ان المجتمعين لم يغلقوا الباب
كاملا امام الدبلوماسيه وامهل المجلس
العسكري اسبوعا لاعاده النظام الدستوري
واعاده الرئيس محمد بازون الى السلطه
ان ايفنت
[موسيقى]
باثارنا من طرف السلطات في غضون اسبوع
قررت المجموعه اتخاذ جميع التدابير
اللازمه لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في جمه
وريه النيجر قد تشمل هذه التدابير استخدام
القوه
[موسيقى]
وفي مشهد مشابه لما جرى فيباماكو قبل اشهر
رفع المتظاهرون العلم الروسي واظهرت مقاطع
فيديو بثتها حسابات محليه مهاجمه عدد من
مؤيد الانقلاب لمقر السفاره الفرنسيه في
نيام
هجمات استدعى التلويحا من باريس برد فوري
في حال التعرض لمصالحها او دبلوماسيين او
قواتها واكد بيان صدر عن الاليزيدعم فرنسا
لكل المبادرات الاقليميه لعوده الرئيس الى
السلطه وتتصدر مجموعه ايكووس التعامل
الافريقيه مع ازمه النيجر
وايكواس او المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا منظمه سياسيه واقتصاديه تاسست عام
تضم خمسه عشره دوله ويتيح الميثاق
التاسيسي لها اتخاذ اجراءات بحق دول اعضاء
من ضمنها بحث امكانيه التدخل عسكريا عبر
قوه فصل افريقيه للتدخل في وقت الازمات
وتعرف باسم قوه ايكوموك
سبق لايكووس ان استخدمت قواتها في عده دول
اما في شكل قوات لحفظ السلام كما في الحرب
الاهليه بكل من كود ديفوار وليبيريا او
تدخل عسكري مباشر من اجل تسليم السلطه
للرئيس المنتخب وهو ما حدث في كوت ديفوار
ايضا وجامبيا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الان الينا من عاصمه النيجر نيامي
الدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور علي اذا
عقوبات
مهل وعيد كيف تتعامل سلطه الانقلاب مع كل
هذا
والله على كل حال الامر مؤقت جدا ولكن سبق
ان امي دوله مالي نفس المعامله ومرت
الامور بسلام ان شاء الله لن يكون هناك
مشكله باذن الله لو في تكاتك بين الشاب
والسلطه ممكن اشد حتى من هذا
انتهت السلام لله الحمد ولا تتوقع قد يكون
في انفراج انفراج بمعنى ماذا
يعني ممكن تفاعله لان اليوم رئيس
لم نسمع شيء عنها لكن لعل قد يكون فيه
تفاور ولكن
يؤثر سلبيا بمعنى الكلمه الدوله او انا
الاسكر ليتنازلوا اول شيء لان الشاب صراحه
معهم يؤيدونهم بقوه كمان
ولكن هل فعلا قاده الانقلاب يمسكون بزمام
الامور حاليا لان التهديدات كبيره تهديدات
من
نوع من التدخل وايضا من من اطراف مختلفه
الى اي حد فعلا هناك يعني السيطره على
الوضع
على كل هذه الحال الى الان
بعد قرارات الى الان ما قالوا شيء
سمينه شيء من الجيش لا ادري من هنا الى
السباس يقولون شيء على كل الشرائحه محليا
انا في العاصمه في وسط العاصمه ما في شيء
ما في ما في شيء مخيف صراحه ما الناس
يتوقعون هذا لانه
وقت النيجر في انقلاب على طنجه نفس الشيء
ولكن بدون
تخطي جوي
واغلاق الحدود وكذا هذه المره فيه نوع من
الشده اكثر
مهله اعطيت لمده اسبوع ما الذي تتوقع ان
يحدث خلال هذا الاسبوع برايك
والله اتوقع امرين
الامر الاول ما المفاوضات ممكن سيكون هناك
هذا الذي نحبزه لو حدث والامر الثاني
الامر يبقى كما هو
كما حدث في مالي هذا الذي
يتعاونون مع مالي وبوركينيا ويكونوا قتله
اخرى قتل عسكريه في غرب افريقيا نعم ولكن
تدخل عسكري
ليس وارد بمعنى الكلمه لا يكون سهلا لانهم
يخافون من اراقه الدماء وهذا سيؤدي الى
اضافه
اشكرك دكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي اذا كنت معنا من ميامي
والان ينضم الينا من لندن اليكس فاينز
مدير برنامج افريقيا في
هاوس اهلا وسهلا بك السيد فاينز اذا كيف
ترى انت الوضع هل فعلا الامر
جاد من جانب الاكواس بتدخل خصوصا انهم
اعطوا مهله ام انه
مجرد تهديد وكلام
والتطبيق شيء اخر
شكرا جزيلا على استضافتي انا اعتقد ان
الامر جدي والتهديد جدي من قبل المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول الغرب افريقيا او ما يعرف
لان تدرس تدخل عسكريا وكما ذكر
الضيف السابق فقد كان هنالك سابقا حيث كان
هنالك تدخل في الانقلاب الذي حدث في
جمهوريه غامبيا في عام 2017
طلبت من المخططين في مجال الدفاع والمجال
العسكري ان يبداوا بالتخطيط وبالتالي فان
المجلس العسكري في النيجر اليوم اصدروا
بيانا ذكروا في بانهم يعارضون اي تدخل
عسكري
هنالك مهله او انذار لمده اسبوع وهذا ما
يعطي هامشا للتفاوض والرئيس
النيجيري الذي يراس مجموعه
او فدى الرئيس التشادي الى العاصمه
اعتقد ان هذا يعبر عن مدى جديه الوضع
وكما ورد كما جاء على لسان الضيف السابق
فان هنالك هامشا ليتفاوضوا ولكن اختلفوا
معه بشان عدم استعدادها للتدخل
فالرئيس هو طبعا القي عليه القبض من قبل
مسؤولين الحكومية ولا اعتقد ان هذا يعني
عن
قد تغيرت وهذه رساله التي التي صدرت عن
قمه في العاصمه ايبوجا عاصمه نيجيريا
تمت اصرار من البعض في داخل النيجر بانه
ما حدث هو مسار تصحيحي
والى اي حد فعلا هناك وزن لهذا الكلام ام
اننا نتحدث عن سياق خارجي بحث
ما حدث في النيجر وهو
انقلاع ابا من قبل
مسؤولين
حكوميين وطبعا نعرف ان الرئيس الرئيس
هو من الاقليه والرئيس تشان
وكان يراس الحرس
الرئاسي واصبح رئيس المجلس العسكري وكان
حليفا للرئيس السابق ولكن كان على وشك
التعاعد من منصبه لذلك ربما هناك امور
تحدث على الصعيد الداخلي ما يقلقني هو ان
الازمه في النيجر قد تاخذ بعدا دوليه
ووزير الخارجيه الروسي
شجبه الانقلاب وطبعا السيد
قائد احدى القوى القوات المرتزقه رحب
بالانقلاب وبالتالي نرى روسيا الاتحاديه
او جزء منها ربما ينظر ينظر الى فرص
يستغلها وراينا اعلاما ورايات روسيه
رفعت في المظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي
شهدتها النيجر خلال الايام الماضيه
استندنا الى ذلك واذا كنا فقط نتحدث عن
اعلام ترفع هكذا من قبل بعض الاشخاص اذا
ما حصل فعلا الى اي مدى يمكن فعلا ان يخل
بالمنظومه الامنيه ككل المنطقه
طبعا النيجر هي دوله ذات اهميه استراتيجيه
خاضت عددا من المعارك ضد الارهابيين
الاسلاميين المنتمونه
لتنظيم الدوله والقاعده وهي الدوله رقم
سبعه من حيث انتاج اليورانيوم
وتاتي من مناجم اليورانيوم وهذا ما يعطيها
اهميه استراتيجيه والولايات المتحده لها
حوالي
1200 عنصر او عسكريه في قاعده وكذلك
الفرنسيون والالمان لهم وجود عسكري ولذلك
الوضع
ربما اصبح مدونه
من افقر دول العالم
وتعتمد على مساعدات
عموميه بمقدار مليار دولار
سنويا وبالتالي فان ضغط مجموع الاقتصاديه
لدول الدول الغرب افريقيا ينبغي ان تؤخذ
على نحو جديد ولا اعتقد ان نيجيريا يمكن
ان تسمح بانقلاب عسكريين اخر يحدث في غرب
افريقيا
اشكرك الك مدير برنامج افريقيا في معهد
شاتم هاوس شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
حدود قدرات الاكوس والادوات التي تستطيع
التدخل عبرها والامثله السابقه على ذلك
اسئله عديده نحاول الاجابه عنها ضمن فقره
في المتابعه بعد قليل
ونبقى في القاره الافريقيه
وجدل النفوذ الدولي المتمدد فيها ففي
الكونغو الديمقراطيه نددت الحكومه بما
وصفته
بتبديد ثروات البلاد عبر اتفاقيه التعاون
الموقعه عام 2006 مع مجموعه شركات صينيه
لاستخراج معدن الكوبالت وقد كشف تقرير
للمفتش العام للماليه في الكونغو ان هذه
الشركات حققت عوائد ماليه تقدر بعشرات
مليارات الدولارات
الزميل محمد الطيب وضمن الملف الخاص عن
التنافس الدولي في افريقيا يكشف لنا واقعه
مناجم الكوبالت في الكونغو واثار السياسات
الصينيه في التعامل مع هذه الثروات
[موسيقى]
ارضها بكر مكسوه بالخضره وباطنها يكتنز
الثروات الدوله الثانيه في افريقيا من حيث
المساحه والثالثه من حيث عدد السكان انها
جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
مقاطعه لالوبا تنام وتصحو عاصمتها كوليزي
على اهم كنوز الارض وهي غارقه في فقرها
نقص في الخدمات وتواضع في البناء التحتيه
اهميه هذه المقاطعه بالنسبه للعالم كبيره
جدا لذلك غضت موطنا للتنافس بين الدول
العظمى وكبريات الشركات في العالم جوالك
الذي تحمله وحاسبك الشخصي الذي تستخدمه
والسيارات كهربائيه وارواح الطاقه الشمسيه
واي منتج يعتمد على البطاريه في تشغيل
يحتاج بالتاكيد الى ما تحت ارض هذه
المنطقه وهو الكوبالت العنصر الرئيسي في
صناعه البطاريه وحفظ الطاقه
[موسيقى]
في هذا المنجب المتاخم لطرف المدينه هنا
يقضي اليكسمبو سحابه نهاره بحثا عن
الكوبالت عبر طرق التنقيب الشعبيه يدرك ان
ما يستخرجونه يوازي الذهب والنفط غير انه
ورفاقه يتلقون اجرا هزيلا يعزوا الامر الى
سيطره الشركات الصينيه على السوق
انهم يهتمون فقط باستثماراتهم الخاصه ليس
لديهم منافسون هنا سوى انفسهم لذا فان
السوق تحت ايديهم الاسعار التي يقدمونها
لنا سيئه
انتجت ارض الكونغو ما يقارب ثلاثه ارباع
الانتاج العالمي للكوبالت العام الماضي
وبكميه تعد الاكبر مقارنه بالدول المنتجه
الاخرى مثل روسيا واستراليا كما تملك نصيب
الاسد من الاحتياط العالمي
صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي حصلت عليها
الجزيره وقام بتحليلها فريق فني متخصص
رصدت نشاط الشركات الصينيه فيما يعرف
بحزام الكوبال تلك التنجي جنوبي البلاد
وتؤكد نتائج تحليل واحداثيات صور المناجم
سيطره الصين على اغلبها في الكونغو سواء
بالتشكيل او بالشراء من المنكبين المحليين
وعلى امتداد مساحه شاسعه في مقاطعه
استحوذت الشركات الصينيه على التنكيب
نتيجه اتفاقات ابرمت عام 2006 تمنحها
امتيازات في التنقيب والشراء مقابل تطوير
البنى التحتيه وتعطيها كلمه الفصل في
تحديد اسعار الكوبالت الذي تشتريه من
المستخرجين
وحسب احصائيات رسميه فان مهنه التنقيب عن
المعادن هي اكثر المهن رواجا في البلاد لا
سيما في منطقه لالوبا حيث اغلب مناجم
التعدين في الجنوب لكن المعدنين على ما
يبدو تحتوي صايه صينيه بلا منافس ولا رقيب
في التحكم باسعار شراء الكوبالت
تغيير النظام الحالي يتطلب منا تحديد
مناطق استكشاف خاصه بالمعدنين المحليين
مموله من غير الصينيين هذه الطريقه
الوحيده لتحسين النظام
حكومه كينشاسا نددت في منتصف فبراير هذا
العام بما وصفته بعدم التوازن وشجب
التبديده ثروات البلاد عبر اتفاقيه
التعاون مع مجموعه شركات الصينيه سيكامينز
الموقعه عام 2006 وذكر تقرير مفتش عام
الماليه ان عوائد الدوله من الاتفاقات
المبرمه مع صينيين لم تحقق غاياتها وانها
ضعيفه مقارنه بمكاسب الشركات
الخلل الذي رصدناه صارخ عبر هذا الاتفاق
تم بيع وتبديد معادننا وهناك ايضا عدد من
ابناء بلدنا المضللين كانت لهم يد مع
الشركات الصينيه في هذا العمل المروع ضد
بلدنا
الاتفاقات مع الشركات الصينيه تضمن قائمه
طويله من مشروعات البناء التحتيه المختلفه
بينها الخدمات والاسكان والطاقه الا ان
حكومه كينشاسا تجزم انه لم يتحقق اي منها
على ارض الواقع
مراجعه العقود مع الشركات الصينيه
وادانتها بمخالفات ربما تدفعان الحكومه
الكنغوليه الى فتح الباب امام دول وشركات
اخرى للاستثمار في هذا القطاع الحيوي بعد
الخيبات التي جنتها من العمل مع الصين
قياده اعتقد انه في الوقت الراهن غدت هذه
المعادن استراتيجيه يعلم الجميع انه يتعين
علينا مشاركه الانتاج بشكل عادل كما يدرك
الصينيون ذلك جيدا والانتاج اليوم يكفي
لاطعام السوق الصيني والسوقنا المحلي
يؤمن الكونغوليون ان بلادهم تعد احد كنوز
افريقيا الثمينه وانما فيها من صراع او
هدر لثروات انما هو نتيجه تنافس دولي
عليها وافاقات اداريه ورقابيه وسياسيه من
قادتها ويوظفت امكانياتها فانها موعوده
بان تكون في مصافي الدول الغنيه والمتقدمه
كما تامل هذه الاغنيه الشهيره عندهم ان
تكون دره اقتصادي افريقيه وتاجا لنهضتها
ونمائها محمد الطيب الجزيره في مقاطعه
لالوبا
[موسيقى]
لان الى لبنان تحديدا مخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين الذي يعيش على وقع
توتر متصاعد اثر اشتباكات اسفلت عن مقتل
سته اشخاص بينهم قائد قوات الامن الوطني
الفلسطيني في منطقه صيدا ابو اشرف
العرموشي وفي حين شددت حركه فتح على ان ما
حدث لن يمر دون محاسبه قال رئيس حكومه
تصريف الاعمال في لبنان نجيب ميقاتي ان
توقيت الاشتباكات مشبوه في الظرف الاقليمي
والدولي الراهن داعيا الى احترام سياده
البلاد
مشهد يريدك ان تالفه
فلعين الحلوه قصص مع التوتر
الاشتباكات المسلحه الاحداث في واحد من
اكبر مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
لبنان اندلعت ليلا وتجددت الظهراء
كانت الاشتباكات الليليه قد اعقبت محاوله
اغتيال تعرض لها ناشط اسلامي في المخيم ثم
استانفت في اليوم التالي باسلحه الرشاشه
والقذائف الصاروخيه بعيد اجتماع لهيئه
العمل الفلسطيني المشترك للقوه الوطنيه
والاسلاميه
المواجهات بين المسلحين اوقعت قتله بينهم
العميد ابو اشرف العرموشي قائد الامن
الوطني الفلسطيني بمنطقه صيدا واربعه من
مرافقيه
حركه فتح التي نعت العرموشي ومرافقيه
الاربعه اتهمت في بيان جهات وصفتها
بالمشبوهه بقتله واشارت الى انها لن تسمح
بان تمر هذه الجريمه من دون محاسبه
مرتكبيها على حد تعبيرها كل يعبر
بمصطلحاته لكن الجميع هنا ازاء جرح اخر
على مخيم عين الحلوه اي لملمه
وعلى ذكر الجروح فقد اعلن الجيش اللبناني
اصابه احد عسكرية جراء سقوط قذيفه داخل
احد المراكز العسكريه في محيط المخيم
قوات الامن اللبنانيه وجهت دعوه لاهالي
صيدا الى التزام الحيطه والحذر اما رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي فدعى
القيادات الفلسطينيه للتعاون مع الجيش
ببسط الامن
ميقات وصف توقيت الاشتباكات الفلسطينيه في
مخيم عين الحلوه بانه مشبوه
ليست توتر المعبر عنه بالسلاح بالامر
الجديد على المخيم حيث دارت اشتباكات
المماثله قبل نحو شهرين فقط قد تختلف
الظروف المحيطه بكل توتر غير ان مخيمات
اللجوء في لبنان لطالما بدت الكثيرين
انعكاسا للداخل الفلسطيني بكل تعدده
وتباينه
وانضم الان الينا من بيروت هيثم ابو
الغزلان امين سر العلاقات في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي لبنان اهلا وسهلا بك سيد هيثم
اذا انتم كفصيل فلسطيني كيف تنظرون الى
السياق الذي تاتي فيه هذه الاشتباكات في
مخيم عين الحلوه
بكل تاكيد ان ما حصل لا يبدو انه بريء
بكل هذه
استخدام هذا السلاح بهذا التوقيت وفي ظل
وجود هذا الكم الهائل من البشر داخل ومن
اهلنا داخل المخيم الفلسطيني ومتى وما حصل
من تضرر سواء سقوط ضحايا سته شهداء
وعشرات من الجرحى وايضا ما حصل من تضرر
لاهالينا من
تركهم لمنازلهم وتضرر هذه المنازل وحرق
المنازل كل هذا يشكل لا يشير الى ان هذا
الامر امرا بريئا بكل تاكيد ان ما حصل
واستخدام هذا السلاح بهذه الطريقه لا يخدم
القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا يخدم المشروع
الفلسطيني انه لا يبدو بريئا ما الذي
تقصده تحديدا ماذا يعني هذا الكلام
بكل تاكيد عندما يستخدم السلاح بهذه
الطريقه ويغتال العميد اشرف ابو اشرف
العرموشي وهو الذي كان ذاهبا في مهمه
لاصلاحيه وايضا للمعالجه جيول ما حصل
بالامس بكل تاكيد ان هذا الامر ليس بريئا
وخصوصا ان القضيه الفلسطينيه الان تمر
بصعوبات عديده على الصعيد الاقليمي
والصعيد الدولي هناك هبوط على فلسطين
يعني ما الذي تقصده هل تقصد ان هناك ايادي
خارجيه ام ماذا
يعني فقط ساعدنا ان نفهم اكثر ما تقصده
بكل تاكيد ان هناك من نفذ هذا المشروع
وهذه
القضايا غير البريئه التي ادت الى اشتعال
هذه الاوضاع بوقت ليس
ليس بريء
وفي اثاره هذه المشاكل بهذه الطريقه برايك
في هذا المخيم تحديدا
طبعا عين الحلوه هي رمز للاجئين
الفلسطينيين
وجود هذا المخيم يشكل عائق كبير امام يمنع
من
تصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وايضا خصوصا ما
بعد معركه جنين التي اصبح فيها المخيم
الفلسطيني رمز للمقاومه ورمز للعوده ولحق
العوده ولذلك يجب ان يبقى هذا السلاح
الفلسطيني في المخيمات الفلسطينيه هو
لحمايه
الفلسطينيين وحمايه اهلنا وايضا من اجل ان
يبقى لا ترى لا يرى من خلاله اللاجئون
الفلسطينيون
من اثاره هذه الامور الان بهذه الطريقه
وكيف يمكن ان تتعامل معها سواء الفصائل او
الجيش اللبناني مع ما يجري
بكل تاكيد ان العدو الصهيوني هو المستفيد
الاكبر مما يحصل وهناك كانت اليوم جهود
بذلت على اكثر من صعيد واكثر من جهه
فلسطينيه ولبنانيه وبجهود مشتركه لبنانيه
فلسطينيه ادت الى
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار وايضا من اجل
معالجه ذيول هذا ما حصل بالامس على ان
ونحن من ندعو من هنا الى ان لا يتكرر هذا
الامر من خلال معالجه كافه ذيول لهذا هذه
القضيه وتسليم كافه المتهمين
او الذين يظهر علاقتهم بهذا الامر الى
السلطات اللبنانيه كونها هي المعنيه
بحمايه او بالقوانين التنفيذ القوانين
اللبنانيه ولذلك ايضا يجب بلسم الجراح
اهلنا الفلسطينيين الذين تضررت منازلهم او
الذين جرحوا او قتلوا وبالتالي يجب ان
يعمل الجميع من اجل انهاء كافه ذيول هذه
القضيه بما يخدم المخيم الفلسطيني وبما
يخدم قضيه اللاجئين الفلسطينيين حيث تم
ابو الغزلان امين سر العلاقات في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي لبنان شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى روسيا الان التي شهدت اليوم هجوما
جديدا بالمسير سيارات استهدف العاصمه اذ
اعلنت السلطات اسقاط الثلاثي مسيرات في
العاصمه موسكو وخمس 25 مسيره في شبه جزيره
القرم وقال الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ان
الحربه تعود تدريجيا الى الاراضي الروسيا
اما وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه فقد اتهمت
كييف بشن ما سمته هجوما ارهابيا بالمسيرات
بمساعده الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في
النيتو
المسيرات وسيله اوكرانيا لنقل الحرب الى
العاصمه الروسيه مره اخرى تطلق اوكرانيا
مسيرات على موسكو حسب السلطات الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها اسقطت
ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه وان شخصا اصيب بجروح
ناتجه اصطدام مسيره باحد الابراج ادى
الهجوم الى اغلاق مطار ابن كوفو في موسكو
لبعض الوقت وبغض النظر عن حجم الاضرار
يشكل وصول هذه المسيرات الى وسط العاصمه
الروسيه ازعاجا للكرملين فموسكو توجد على
بعد نحو 500 كيلومتر من الحدود الاوكرانيه
وقطع المسيرات الاوكرانيه كل هذه المسافه
يطرح اكثر من علامات استفهام وهذا لم يحدث
مره واحده فقد وصلت مسيرات في السابق الى
موسكو بل ان مسيرتين وصلتا الى الكرملين
في مايو الماضي الرئيس الاوكراني علق على
الهجوم بالقول ان الحرب قادمه الى روسيا
زيلينسكي تابع قائلا ان الحربه تعود
تدريجيا الى اراضي روسيا الى مراكزها
الرمزيه وقواعدها العسكريه واعتبر ذلك
تطورا طبيعيا وعادلا تماما لا يخلو كلام
من تحدي لروسيا التي اتهمت على لسان وزاره
خارجيتها الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في
النيتو بمد كييف بالمسيرات تبقى المسيرات
سلاح كييف المفضل للوصول الى موسكو لتحقيق
انجاز معنوي لا تخفى اهميته وضرب مواقع في
شبه جزيره القرم السلطات الروسيه قالت
انها اسقطت 25 مسيره اطلقتها كييف على شبه
الجزيره يشير الرقم الى ان شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وتطالب
اوكرانيا باسترجاعها تبقى الهدف الاول
للمسيرات الاوكرانيه فقد سبق ان استهدفت
كييف مواقع عسكريه الروسيه في شبه الجزيره
مرات عديده
ايضا المسيرات لضرب مواقع كثيره في
اوكرانيا منها العاصمه لكن الفرق ان الجيش
الروسي يمكنه الوصول الى كل هذه المواقع
باسلحه اخرى اما الجيش الاوكراني
فالمسيرات هي وسيلته الوحيده لضرب مواقع
لا تسعفه امكانياته وظروفه للوصول اليها
بوسائل اخرى
كان هذا في العاصمه الروسيه والقرم اما
الداخل اوكرانيا فقد اعلنت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها تعرضت لهجوم روسي خلال
الليت الليله الماضيه باربع طائرات مسيره
من الجنوب الشرقي للبلاد واشارت الى تدمير
اربع مسيرات روسيه في اتجاه خرسون
خلال اليوم الماضي
الان الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك عميد الياس اذا هل نحن بصدد الحديث عن
نسق عسكري اوكراني جديد اذا ما فعلا صحه
هذه الاتهامات الروسيه
الليله هناك ثلاثه محاور مهمه تستعملها
اوكرانيا بحذر والهدف دائما هو قطع الجسر
البري يعني هناك موضوع مخموت هناك تقدم
اساسي في الوسط باتجاه برديانس وفي الغرب
تقريبا من اوريكييف باتجاه توك ماركوب
ثلاثه محاور اساسيه تصل الى البحر الاسود
او بحر ازوف والهدف دائما هو تقطيع هذه
المنطقه وضرب الجسر البري الوسائل مختلفه
اليوم الوسائل يعني استعمال كثيف للمسيرات
هناك تنظيم جيش
مسيرات اوكرانيا في المقابل جيش مسيرات
روسي بدا العمل هذا امر مهم جدا هناك 200
شركه ليلى تصنع المسيرات في اوكرانيا حتى
اريك يعني هو مدير الجوجل السابق استثمر
عشره ملايين دولار بهذه الصناعه مع
استعمال الذكاء الاصطناعي وهذا امر فريد
من نوعه من هنا تسميتها بانها حرب
المسيرات في القرن 21 وفي حرب المسيرات
هذه من له اليد العليا وهل تستطيع
اوكرانيا ان يعني تدعم هذه الحرب
بوسائل اخرى
ليلى المسيرات هي عنصر مساعد للحرب
الاساسيه التي تدور على جبهه طولها 900 كم
يعني الهدف دائما هو الهجوم
ضرب الجيش الروسي
واخراجه والوصول الى البحر الاسود وبحر
ازوف ولكن هناك الوسائل الوسائل هي مدفعيه
طيران هندسه دبابات مشات وما شابه وهذا
امر يستلزم جهد اساسي المسيرات تلعب دور
مساعد في هذه ولكنها لا تنهي ولكنها لا
تربح الحرب من هنا هي عامل مساعد لحرب
طويله وقد تكون اكثر دمويه في المراحل
القادمه
وهل فعلا يمكن ان يكون لها تاثير في
الاداء الروسي في الفتره القادمه يعني هل
سنشهد تغير في الطريقه التي تتعامل فيها
روسيا بسبب هذه اله جمات بسبب هذا التهديد
والحديث عن ان روسيا يجب ان تعي ان الرد
داخل اراضيها سيكون حتميا
الهدف الروسي حاليا هو البقاء في المناطق
واتخاذ الموقع الدفاعي وبالتالي ضرب العمق
الاوكراني باكثر قدر من المسيرات ان كان
من صنع روسي وبدانا نرى انتاج روسي سريع
او من صنع ايراني شاهد وما شابه بالاضافه
الى الصواريخ لجعل اوكرانيا غير قادره على
القيام بهجوم العكسي
واحداث اي تقدم اساسي وبالتالي الثبات في
هذه الموقعه بانتظار ان يصل الهجوم
الاوكراني الى مذاهب الاقصى او ما يسمى
بالكلمينيشن ونذهب الى مرحله ستايل ميت
وبالتالي الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات او
بقاء الوضع كما هو اشكرك كالعميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
وفي سياق عسكريا روسيا يتجاوز الحرب في
اوكرانيا اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين خلال العرض العسكري السنوي في سان
بيتر سبيرج بمناسبه يوم تاسيس الاسطول
البحري انا البحريه الروسيه وقفت مرارا في
وجه من سماهم الاعداء كحصن منيع مشيرا الى
ان بلاده تنفذ بثقه ما وصفها بمهامه
سياسيه بحريه واسعه النطاق
من سنه التي اسس فيها قيصر روسيا بطرس
الاكبر واسطولا امبراطوريته يستعرض الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قدرات هذا الاسطول
المعاصره
استعراض محمل برسائل جيوسيه لعالم يبدو
اليوم مقبلا براي بوتين على تغييرات جذريه
لقد وقف الاسطول الروسي مرارا حصنا منيعا
في وجه الاعداء اليوم تنفذ روسيا بثقه
مهام سياسيه بحريه واسعه النطاق وتوسع
باستمرار قوه اسطولها وخلال هذا العام
انضمت 30 سفينه من فئات مختلفه الى
الاسطول
من ابرز الحاضرين قاده السلطات الانتقاليه
في بوركينا فاسو ومالي
قاده عسكريون قرروا الخروج من عباءه فرنسا
بحثا عن ظل تحت جناح روسيا
مشاركه تحمل رمزيه كبيره في مساحه
الاستفافات الناشئه
اعتمدت
روسيا حواجز تمنع تحركات اسطولها في
المحيطات والبحار
انفقت روسيا المليارات على تطوير بحريتها
وانطلقت اساطيلها الخمسه في كل الاتجاهات
شاركت قطاعها البحريه في عمليات عسكريه
بسوريا كما اجرت تدريبات مشتركه مع الصين
وايران في جغرافيه كانت تاريخيا ضمن فضاء
المنافس الامريكي
ولعبت السفن الحربيه وما تزال دورا رئيسيا
في حرب اوكرانيا رغم بعض الاخفاقات
المؤلمه كخساره الطراد موسكو وسفن انزال
والاستهداف المتكرر لقاعده اسطول البحر
الاسود في القرن يشلف
لدى روسيا القدره على ان تصبح قوه بحريه
عظمى ليست لدينا مشاكل فيما يخص الغواصات
والسفن ولكن لدينا مشكله مع حاملات
الطائرات هل نبنيها بانفسنا ام نذهب الى
خيارات بديله هناك عقبات ايضا متعلقه
بتخلينا السهل عن قواعدنا البحريه في
العالم
[موسيقى]
طموح روسيا التاريخيه لتكون قوه بحريه
عالميه عظمى طالما اصطدم بالتحديات كثيره
اهمها اختلال موازين القوى وقدرات
الاقتصاد الروسي تحديات ما تزال واقعيه
وموضوعيه في راي كثيرين زاوى الجزيره
[موسيقى]
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى افاد مراسل الجزيره في
باكستان انا اكثر من 46 شخصا قتلوا واصيب
150 اثر تفجير يشتبه بانه انتحاري في بلده
خار في محافظه باجور التابعه الاقليمي
خيبر شمال غربي باكستان ونقل المراسل عن
مصدر امني ان الانفجار وقع اثناء اجتماع
حزبي لاعضاء ومنتسبي جمعيه علماء الاسلام
وهو حزب سياسي ديني مشارك في الحكومه
الائتلافيه
بحث وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد اللهيان في طهران مع الممثله الخاصه
للامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون العراق
جنين هنس
التفاهمات الامنيه بين طهران وبغداد
وضروره تنفيذها وذكرت وزاره الخارجيه
الايران وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه ان عبد
اللهيان اكد خلال اللقاء ان العلاقات بين
ايران والعراق تؤثر ايجابيا على التنميه
والامن المستدام في المنطقه
خرجت مسيرته شعبيه نظمتها حركه حماس في
مناطق متفرقه بقطاع غزه للمطالبه برفع
الحصار الاسرائيلي المفروض على القطاع
ورفع المشاركون في المسيرات شعارات تشيد
بالمقاومه الفلسطينيه وتطالب برفع الحصار
عن القطع
هذا بينما انطلق في رام الله مهرجان
فلسطين الدولي وذلك تحت شعار الشهداء
والاسرى حاضرون ياتي المهرجان هذا العام
في الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين لنكبه فلسطين
تاكيدا على انها حدث مفصلي وانها حق
العوده لا يسقطوا بالتقادر
المستهدف هو الحب وذوق الجمالي والانساني
ما ابسط الاحلام ما اعظم الانسان ما اصغر
المكان ما اكبر الفكره بهذه الكلمات انطلق
مهرجان فلسطين الدولي
[موسيقى]
انها رساله الاسير المفكر المريض وليد دقه
لابنته ميلاد التي لا يعرفها رساله
المهرجان كانت اولا للاسرى والشهداء وان
الاحتلال لن يحاصره الفلسطينيين
اقيم المهرجان في الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين
لنكبه فلسطين وشعاره مفتاح العوده
المفتاح الذي يلم شمل الشعب الفلسطيني
اينما وجد في الشتات وفي الداخل وايضا هذا
المفتاح يعلق على صدورنا وفي بيوتنا لكي
نقول انه حق العوده لا يسقط بالتقادم
فرقه ابيدر تضم فنانين من اسبانيا والسويد
والاهم من فلسطينيين هجرت عائلاتهم عاما
نكبه
الاوركسترا العربيه اكثر من 70 عازفا
وهذا الشاب الذي يعزف على اليرغول من مخيم
جنين الحاضر بعد العدوان
من مصر والاردن ودول غربيه
جميعهم وجدوا ان الغناء في فلسطين ليس كاي
مكان فلسطين بالنسبه لي مثل الحلم انا
اليوم سعيد انه انا موجوده هون وبنفس
الوقت الغناء رساله لانه احنا بنحاول
نحافظ على التراث الاصيل
اما الغائب الحاضر فهم الشهداء من بينهم
عضو الهيئه الاداريه للمهرجان شيرين ابو
عاقل
[موسيقى]
بطلت لون البرتقالي بزرقه البحر وخيوط
الثوب بجذور الزيتون فكان مفتاح العوده
شعار المهرجان ليؤكد مجددا على ان الثقافه
والفنون توحد الشعوب وتخترق جدران الصمت
وتنقل فلسطين الى العالم
[موسيقى]
ونعود الان الى الاكواس التي تحضر بشكل
قوي في السياق الخبري اليوم
اذ تتخذ اجراءات وتتحدث عن دور قد يصل الى
التدخل المباشر في حالات عدم الاستقرار
سواء في النيجر او غيرها لكن هل تستطيع
هذه المنظمه فعل ذلك
في المبدا تفاعلت فكره المنظمه في
الستينيات القرن الماضي حين حصلت اغلب دول
منطقه غرب افريقيا على استقلالها فتم
الحديث حينها عن فكره اقامه اطار للتعاون
الاقتصادي والسياسي معا
تندوي تحت مظله المنظمه 15 دوله
كما نرى في هذه المنطقه في هذه الكتله
الجغرافيه وتشكل نحو
17% من مساحه القاره ككل
وللمنظمه اذرع كثيره فيها تنسيق سياسي
واقتصادي ومقرها الرئيسي وفي ابوجا عاصمه
نيجيريا وفيما يتعلق بالضبط العلاقات
والنزاعات يشكل الاقتصاد القوه الاهم
باعتباره وسيله لفرض العقوبات وللحصار
الاقتصادي اندعت الحاجه
ولكن هناك وسائل اخرى ايضا فالمنظمه هي
صاحبه الفضل في تشكيل اول قوه فصل افريقيه
للتدخل وقت الازمات وقد عرفت باسم قوه
الاكوموك ولاحقا تحولت الى قوه ردع تابعه
لمنظمه ضمن تشكيل قوه التدخل والردع
التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي
طبعا لاستخدام هذه الاذرع امثله ابرزها لو
كان في مالي وذلك عقب انقلاب الجيش على
السلطه عام 2020 اذ اتخذت المنظمه اجراءات
كاغلاق الحدود مع مالي وتجميد ارصدتها
قبل ذلك في عام 2003 تحديدا تدخلت المنظمه
في ساحل العاج حين ارسلت قوات حفظ سلام
خلال الحرب الاهليه الاولى ثم تدخلت في
البلد نفسه عام 2011 على خلفيه ازمه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في غامبيا قادت الاكواس عام 2017 تلا
عسكريا لاجبار الرئيس الجامبي يحيى جامي
حينها على تسليم السلطه للرئيس المنتخب في
انتخابات عام 2016
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من جهاز
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
جوهانسبرج والخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه
اذا نحن
اهلا بك طبعا اولا سيد موني اريد ان اسالك
عن التوقعات بالنسبه للاكواس هل الاكواس
اليوم فعلا
قادر على ان يتدخل عسكريا في النيجر
[موسيقى]
التدخلات السابقه وعلى ضوء التهديدات التي
التي صدرت من اقوى دوله في غرب افريقيا
وهي نيجيريا والتي يراسها الان رئيس جديد
وهو رئيس
الاكواسو والذي يواجه بدوره تحديات جمه في
نيجيريا منها
محاربه تنظيم بوكو حرام ولذلك لا اعتقد
انه يملك قدراتنا عسكريه كافيه
تمكنه من التدخل في الازمه او الوضع
يعني هذا هو محور السؤال لانه يعني اربع
دول حتى الان خرجت او اكثر حتى خرجت من
العباءه الفرنسيه على ما يبدو وتحركت
باتجاه روسيا
وفي يعني تغير
جيوسياسي
ويتعلق بالنفوذ الدولي في محيط النيجر
وهذا يدعو للسؤال سواء اذا كانت هناك تغير
في دول اخرى يدل السؤال عن مستقبل هذه
المنظمه
اين مستقبل
شهد ضعفها لا شك
سيما على ضوء العجز عن التدخل العسكريا في
الشؤون الداخليه في الدولاب نحن نعرف ان
هذه المنظمه هذه المنظومه وهي منظمه
اقتصاديه
لها
عمل او ان النشاطات في مجالات اخرى وكذلك
حققت انجازات اخرى ولكن فيما يتعلق بتعزيز
الديمقراطيه وتوطيدها وتدخل عسكريا
لحل الاضطرابات السياسيه
اكوا شهدت ضعفا الى حد كبير خلال العشره
والخمسه عشر عاما سابقا هي ليست
تحت رئاسه الرئيس
والتي كانت
تتدخل في اوضاع ربما تستطيع تدخل من قبل
هذه المنظمه في السابق دكتور ديفيد مانيي
استاذ العاقه الدوليه في جامعه والخبير في
الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
150 الف ضحيه تم الاتجار بهم خلال عامي
2021 و 2022
هذا ما تمكن من رصده واحصائه بحسب المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره
150 الفا سلبوا ارادته وباتوا يباعون
ويشترون كالعبيد جلهم من النساء والاطفال
شتتتهم الحروب والكوارث
وانقاذهم
مسؤوليات الجميع
نهايه الحصاد
شكرا لكم على المتابعه وفي
[موسيقى]